good morning Hank it's Tuesday the ice
I'm skating on is getting pretty thin at
the moment that line incidentally has
become such a cliche that it's easy to
forget how terrifying it would be to
actually skate on thin ice like as you
glide away from shore you become
progressively less certain that the
ground beneath you will hold which come
to think of it is not a terrible
metaphor for 2020 now I am conscious of
how incredibly fortunate I am in these
hard times to have a safe place to live
work I can do from home a healthy family
and so on but nonetheless I am
struggling for starters I'm burnt out
not just with work but also like a lot
of parents I know with the challenges of
trying to help kids through a time of
immense uncertainty and also the
constant management and analysis of
exposure risk also there's just the
mental health problems that I brought
into this like the endless thought
whoops and stultifying compulsions of
OCD are nothing if not annoyingly
monotonous and there is something a
little soul-destroying about being
forced to think the same thoughts over
and over and over again regardless of
whether they're useful or productive but
this is a video about joy and hope and I
will get to that but first I feel this
ice is getting pretty thin feeling not
just personally but also on a macro
level because my nation is experiencing
an explosion of new co vid 19 cases even
as many other countries are making
serious progress with the pandemic and
that's frustrating like last week in my
home state of Indiana which has a
population under seven million people
there were more nuke ovid cases and
deaths than there were in the nation of
Germany which has a population of over
83 million people an Indiana is one of
the better states Cova DeWyze it is so
frustrating and heartbreaking to see so
much unnecessary suffering and death
caused by the failure of our political
and public health systems and I don't
know what to do about it I feel
overwhelmed by the problem and powerless
before it I mean the last 12 weeks have
been the deadliest 12-week period in the
United States in many decades and there
are still people saying this is a hoax
but I'm trying to make this a video
about hope and joy okay so Hank now that
your book has been out for a week I feel
like I can share my favorite quote from
it there's no spoilers in it or anything
there are many great lines in the book
and my copy is extensively dog-eared but
my favorite line is you will always
struggle with not feeling productive
until
you accept that your own joy can be
something you produce it is not the only
thing you make nor should it be but it
is something valuable and beautiful god
I love that line Hank I was thinking
about it last night as I got out of bed
around midnight because I couldn't sleep
and I was like you know what I'm gonna
produce some of my own joy and then I
spent the next five hours watching
Robbie Gonzales explained to me how
Rubik's cubes work now Hank you know
that I have very limited spatial
intelligence like I've lived in my
neighborhood for 13 years and I couldn't
draw you a map of it you know those
children's jigsaw puzzles with like 25
pieces I can't do them and yet last
night with the help of Robbie Gonzalez
and anxious insomnia I finished a
Rubik's Cube after 30 years of failure I
did it and in the process I've produced
some of my own joy now it's not like I
made a vlog brothers video or a podcast
episode or answered the emails I'm
behind on but this also wasn't time
wasted Hank that line from your book has
been really revelatory for me because it
has given me permission to produce joy
even when I'm so worried and when so
much is so horrible I must make room for
seeking and making joy because that is
what cultivates hope let me know in
comments if you can where you're trying
to make or find joy these days I really
recommend Rubik's cubes which just to
reiterate I did this with my own two
hands and the help of a step-by-step
youtube tutorial Hank I'll see you on
Friday